let's give a rousing welcome to mr. Hank
Williams
all right boys let it roll hey
good-looking Wow live me a stupendous
hey sweet baby congratulations
yeah son mr. Williams he's going home
real there
not like it was for me hey drinking like
a fish tonight can you run hey little
palm of Lord why don't you write me at
home
I might haven't given nori a little
better there's a lot of speculation
about the hard live set folk singers
living what a may are you go out on the
road and you sleep with a different
woman every night business it's tough on
marriage marriage is tough all marriage
you're barely even here you're barely in
the fun
everybody has a little darkness in him
and I'm talking about things like anger
sorrow shame I sure what do and they
don't have to take it home
[Applause]
you